is AI going to kill us all
uh Maybe
twitch was
Amazon in 2014 joins us now I started
twitch
to help people watch other people play
video games on the internet the Creator
and co-founder of twitch watch other
people play videos I guess that's the
answer
what types of ideas are you noticing or
standing out to you that are interesting
for the first time in maybe five or
seven years it feels like incredibly
trying to start a consumer internet
company like the ones that like I was so
excited to start in 2007 is like
potentially a good idea um that's
because of AI you mentioned AI might
become so intelligent kills us all
this podcast is really growing I don't I
don't want the world to end I think it's
going to be okay
but it's such the downside is so bad
it's like it's really probably worse
than nuclear war
that's a really bad downside
I think of it as a range of uncertainty
and I would say that the true
probability
I believe is somewhere between
[Music]
all right what you're about to hear is a
conversation I had with Emmett sheer
Emmett was the creator and co-founder of
twitch if you don't know about twitch I
know you're living under a rock it's
like one of the most I don't know five
most popular websites in in the states
right now it is a um a place where you
can go to watch other people play video
games of all things watch other people
play video games who knew Emmett new I
guess that's the answer so he was the
creator co-founder of that and um built
it up it's a multi-billion dollar
company they sold to Amazon many years
ago seven years ago or eight years ago
for about a billion dollars and has
grown many times since then uh he
finally retired after 17 years of the
journey
um I got to know Emmett because he
bought my previous company so we got
acquired by twitch
and it was like my you know boss for um
my time when I was at twitch so uh I got
to see this guy firsthand he's the real
deal and I've been wanting to get him on
the podcast since those early days when
I first met him I was like this guy's
great we talked about a bunch of things
so we talked about
um some ideas of like how he would use
AI if he was going to create another
company
um like I think he's good he's retired
now from that game of operating a
company but if he was gonna do it this
is what he would do
um so we talked about AI ideas we talked
about why why he thinks AI might kill us
all might you know be be the big Doom
scenario
um which is interesting because he's not
just a guy who's gonna go cry wolf he's
not a pessimist he's not just a
journalist who hates Tech he's a techno
Optimist this is a guy who believes in
Tech is a um a very very intelligent guy
and he sees you know a probability he
gave us a percentage of probability he
thinks that could be um sort of the
Doomsday scenario and why he thinks that
that could be the case and what we
should do about it so
we talked about AI we talk about some of
the Frameworks that he has for building
companies uh we didn't talk too much
about like the origin of twitch I feel
like he's done that a bunch of times so
we try to kind of stayed away from that
um but it was a wide ranging
conversation and uh for those who are
watching this on YouTube I apologize the
studio that we booked at San Francisco
um they screwed up the video so we don't
have video for the for for YouTube we
just have the audio only version so
you'll see our profile pictures my bad
sorry about that um
you know gotta pick a better place you
gotta pick a better Studio I guess but
um
anyways enjoy this episode with image
here
somebody said creativity is not like a
faucet you can't just turn it on I think
actually if you if you've pulled like
100 people most people like yeah of
course creativity is the sacred special
thing that only happens if you've
meditated in the morning and the room is
perfectly right and you've had your your
l-theanine in your coffee or whatever
and you were like no for me it's very it
is like a faucet watch
I can just write and just keep
generating more ideas yeah I love that
for two reasons one
I love that you'll just be like no
actually this that's like a consistent
thing I've seen you do and the second is
I think that's very true about you and I
wonder is that practiced or is that
innate like if I if there's a researcher
studying you when you were like 10 years
old right do you think they would have
been like oh this this person's
different in these ways what would have
seemed different or special about you at
the time
um
I the if there was a nurture nature
break on this it happened very early
because by the time I was 10
you would definitely notice the same
thing I'm not really that different but
I would be much less effective but like
as a 10 year old I already had that same
experience but you were different than
other 10 year olds yeah other 10 year
olds well I would actually say I was
less different than I think most people
actually most children have this
experience already I think most 10 year
olds and definitely most five-year-olds
are capable of generating ideas for what
to do about something or to like play
pretend almost indefinitely they don't
run out of ideas it's as you get older
somehow you what you learn to do is you
learn to stomp down the ideas that are
like bad
um and to not say dumb things but the
more pressure you put on yourself not to
say dumb things the more your inner idea
generator it like gets disrupted and I
say a lot of dumb things like when I'm
generating ideas I mean I put weight
down on them but most of the ideas will
be bad they'll have something obviously
wrong with them and they give you this
advice and when you if you're like
someone who teaches you how to
brainstorm like no bad ideas here that's
obviously not true there's lots of bad
ideas most of your ideas are bad yeah
the actual advice is like don't stop at
the battery yeah you're what you're
trying to do is you're trying to disable
that sensor that most people have
installed that like is like notepad
notepad notepad don't don't be stupid
don't be stupid and I think I was like
Mal socialized I'd it never occurred to
me to to have that like I I never got
the sensor installed and why that is the
case I'm not sure but I actually I think
I'm the one who is unchanged in some
sense I'm a little more childlike in
that way and everyone else is the weird
one who like why how did you end up like
damaged by your life that you're you're
inner Wellspring of creativity has been
right crushed and I think that process
is actually very simple this process
goes up with all kinds of things in
people's minds you start from
some capability something you can do
some behavior and if when you do that
behavior or you try that thing you
receive negative feedback which can be
external or you actually think even more
often internal you're like oh I screwed
it up oh it's bad oh I don't
disappointment you learn not to do that
thing pretty rapidly and so that leads
you to doing it less which means you're
less skillful at it which kind of leads
you to doing it less which and that
cycle ends in you being very bad at
something like I'm bad at math no you're
not everyone can be like the kind of
math you're talking about everyone can
be the kind of math and people say I'm
bad at math they don't mean I'm bad at
like abstract algebra proofs they mean I
can't do arithmetic or algebra basic
algebra and that's just imaginary like
everyone can do that it's easy they got
stuck in one of these like Spirals and
now it's and getting out of one can be
very hard and I guess I think that's
what happens to people's creativity I
don't know I didn't go through the
process myself and so I got so notice
I'm saying this out loud actually what I
the idea that I have comes up for me is
like oh well maybe what it is is that I
had better ideas
I got the reward Loop or or I had an
environment that was unusually uh
positive and positively reinforcing for
me having ideas and so I would have
ideas
and it would go well that would lead me
to having more ideas which and more
practice at having ideas which would go
well and then you wind up just never
breaking that loop I have a trainer who
comes over to my house and he always
says this thing to me because like my
kids will come down during the session
I'm always like oh sorry like obviously
annoying my two-year-old is here almost
getting hurt on all the weights and
that's probably like not what you want
in your session so I'm always like oh
sorry sorry and he's just like dude no
and he's like
kids and dogs I go what he goes I love
to be around kids and dogs they got it
right they know life he's like a dog is
like unconditional love happy playful
you know super loyal he's like what's
not to learn from a dog I want to learn
everything I care from a dog or kids
he's like look what she's doing she just
made up a game on this thing like we're
here trying to do a serious workout she
made this her play place yeah she can't
wait to come down here he's like I wish
all my clients wanted couldn't wait to
come down to the gym and I was like damn
this guy's right and one of the things I
like is figuring out people's isms their
philosophies and you're like oh I
thought of one on the way here explain
what it was it was have you tried just
solving the problem what does that mean
so there's a there's a meme on the
internet I think I started with weird
Sun Twitter which is like have you tried
solving the problem bye and then an
infinite list of possible the Tweet is
always have you tried solving the
problem by like ignoring the problem
have you tried and solving the problem
by spending more money on it have you
tried solving and one of my favorite
ones of those that has become almost
like a life motto is like if you tried
solving the problem by solving the
problem and
that sounds dumb right like that sounds
it's one of those like Zen cone pieces
of advice that when you first hear it is
like are you are you serious like that's
the advice is solve the problem by
solving the problem but what you noticed
you try to help people with problems a
lot is oftentimes people will have a
problem it was really obvious what the
problem is
and they'll come to you for advice for
like well how can I deal with the
consequences of this problem or how can
I avoid needing to solve this problem or
how can I get someone else to solve this
problem or have other people solve the
problem in the past which is a closer to
the right answer or what can be the
right answer
and the point of the the saying is to
remind you that sometimes the way to
solve the problem is just like just to
actually try solving the problem like
don't deal with the symptoms don't
accept the symptoms don't don't find a
hack around it like the problem is the
website is not fast enough
and instead of like trying to figure out
how we can make a loading spinner that
distracts people from that fact what if
we just made it so fast that you don't
need a loading spinner
it's interesting because that's a good
that's a very good advice when the
problem actually is solvable and your
people are flinching away from it
because something about it is aversive
even though the problem isn't really
unsolvable like they if they worked on
it for six months it would go away and
it's worth solving whereas there are
these problems where like you're trying
to make a professional motion machine
you try to do something that is actually
too hard and
solving the problem by solving the
problem you should actually stop trying
to solve the problem that's a huge
mistake and you should be looking for a
hack around needing to solve the problem
we should be looking to live with it
more effectively but I find actually on
the balance
at least with most people I I talk to I
help most people I know I think it's
maybe it's people in in Tech like love
that love the hack they're always
looking for the easy fast solution that
cuts around and you solve the problem
and it's very helpful it's it's the most
often helpful form of that advice in my
opinion it's like bringing people back
to just solving the problem I find that
the the advice I like the most or the
the sayings that resonate with me the
most are the ones it's like you spot it
you got it it's like if it's the one
it's the advice I needed that's why it
resonates with me that's why I like
giving it out because like I personally
experienced it have you personally
experienced that or what's an example
where you remember trying to do
everything but solve the problem and
then you finally realized I should
have just solved the problem it's an
interesting question what is it you spot
it you got it is like noticing is half
the battle basically it's sort of the
smart person version of whoever smelt
the Delta yeah yeah yeah it's like 100
if you hit you only notice this in other
people because you've seen it in
yourself too yeah otherwise you wouldn't
be as observant of it my version of this
is we give the advice we need to hear
yes
same basic idea it's actually not always
true like that's one of those really
good heuristics where like sure half the
time when you
give advice it won't actually be for you
but half the time it is and noticing it
is so powerful that like you should just
check every piece of advice you give for
like wait a second is this advice I need
to hear right now when it comes to the
like have you tried actually solving the
problem I think I'm pretty good at that
in general I think that I often give it
to myself in a more meta sense like it's
a advice I often needed more medicine of
like when I'm confronted with like a
thing that needs to be programmed I will
often go just program the thing but I
have a tendency to like look for ways
that I can solve the problem and not
that the problem can be solved and for
me that the ver this almost always like
what I wouldn't ask somebody else for
help and I just like it doesn't even
occur to me to go
to go do that I'm just I'll just I'll
just indefinitely dig try to go solve
the problem myself I'm not really trying
to solve the problem I'm trying to solve
the problem while avoiding having to ask
anyone else for help which is like not
real I'm not really trying to solve the
problem but actually no weirdly I think
this is one of those things where it's
almost like the creativity thing it was
a shock for me to realize other people
don't do that so you're self-actualized
on that one yeah what's a piece of good
advice that you're bad at taking oh
that's a that's a an excellent one I
think the big one there is like you know
listen more like I think of this advice
so much at YC and it's 100 something
that I need to get better at which is
like you go into the user interview
and you have all these ideas and
thoughts and you need to
not be surfacing those you need to
actually be focused on you have move
your attention to them and really be
interested and care about what they have
to say and your opinions and what's what
you think is true is irrelevant and I am
I'm much better at that Than I Used to
Be and I I also it's one of those things
like being reminded like let's just tell
it for a second and like listen it's
almost always good advice for me and
something that I and it's nice I give
fairly often but like
uh it's hard for you to take on one of
the things I really liked that you
showed me once I remember asking you
when we're at twitch I think we were
working on a problem that was like
reminiscent of early days twitch uh with
like the whole bubble stuff in different
countries where it's like oh we're not
the leader or we need to like create
from scratch which wasn't a muscle that
a lot of people there were flexing at
the time and I was like hey do you have
any stuff from the early days of Twitter
you sent me a thing which was like
here's all the user interviews like
here's my doc from all the used
interviews did which was basically from
from what I understand there was like a
small Universe of people that were
already doing video game streaming and
you were like cool let me call all of
them and let me ask them like three
questions and if I can just get these
answers these three questions that
should give me a little bit of a road
map a blueprint of understanding what do
I need to do in order to like win in
this market yeah can you take me back to
that because that I like that for two
reasons it was a simple and B seemed
like a focused intensity that you found
a point of Leverage and you pushed yeah
I think two things happened to lead to
that the first was like the realization
obviously in we wanted to win in gaming
the streamers mattered and at Justin TV
we'd always been like streamers and
viewers are equally important and I
finally made a decision I was like no no
this product ultimately is about
streamers and if this doesn't work for
the streamers doesn't work for anybody
and then I had the realization
this is one of those Epiphany moments
where I truly saw
I have no idea why anyone would stream
video games like I don't really want to
do it and I have all these I could I saw
my myself building products for these
people for the past four years just in
TV and not really having any idea why
they did the thing they did at all and I
sort of I saw like oh I'm just making
this up I have no idea I don't know the
answer I could know the answer like they
there is a there is an answer out there
these a bunch of people know it but I
don't and that triggered me to be like I
need to know I need to understand like
these this these 200 people I need to
understand their mind and I did about 40
interviews probably
and I didn't want to know like what they
thought we should build because if they
knew what we should build they would
have my job
and I've talked to enough of them before
to know that they had no good product
ideas I I wanted to know like why are
you streaming you what have you tried to
use for streaming like what did you like
about that like what did how did you get
started in the first place what's your
biggest dream for sharing what do you
wish you know someone would build for
you and I didn't ask them what do I wish
someone would build for you because I
thought they would have a good idea I
asked them because the follow-up
question was really the killer one right
they they would say I wish you would
build me this big red button I'm like
great I built you the big red button
like what what does it do for you like
why is your life better after I built
that and then they would tell me the
real thing which is like oh I would have
made I'd like make up I'd make money
that month or I'd get a bunch of new
fans who like loved me or my fans who
already love me on YouTube would either
watch me live more of them would and I
was like oh that's the real answer like
why you you don't you don't want the
button you want the fans or the money or
the I call it love the like the the
sense of reassurance and and positive
feedback that the your creative content
was wanted but you're a smart guy those
love and money and fans I'm sure you
would have guessed it what do the
streamers want false
what did you think it was a revelation
that people would want money because I
was like you're streaming like you know
whatever 12 hours a week if we met let
you monetize the rates we can monetize
today you'd make like three dollars a
month
that would like that didn't occur to me
that would be a positive thing like yes
oh my God that would be amazing and I
was like wait wait sir you're serious
you would like three dollars I'm like I
don't know over promise like I'll build
you the monetization actually but like
you would really be excited if it only
produced like a tiny amount of money and
they're like absolutely I've just the
idea that I could make money doing this
would be so exciting that had not
occurred to me because it always is easy
for me to make I was a programmer I had
summer jobs interning for Microsoft if
you're a programmer you can get a summer
job and training for Microsoft that's
like pays many many years of that level
of streaming in three months like why
would I it didn't it didn't even it
wasn't in my world view
that that would be so important to them
and of course I knew they wanted a
bigger audience but the degree to which
they valued even one more viewer and the
degreasers they didn't care about
anything else like they they wanted
people to watch them they wanted to make
money and I'd ask about other things
like do you want the video production
you know like improve the video
production have cooler video production
and they'd be like yeah I'd be like okay
but like what what's good about that
like what do you like about that like
well get more I'll get my bigger
audience and it was really the realizing
realization that like it was just those
three things basically explained 98 of
their motivation and we could anything
it didn't move in on that could be
ignored so a good example that's like
polls everyone would ask for polls seems
like a cool feature live polls of course
are you gonna have a bigger audience
with the live polls not particularly are
you going to make more money no
is it does he really if you really feel
more loved if you're running a live poll
than if you're just like asking chat and
having people posted in the chat and say
it no it's the same you got the feedback
it's cool so this product actually comes
with your chat blow up it's cool so
you're saying that this feature is
worthless yes in fact potentially
negative in fact and so it would always
be on the list of like things that would
sound like they might be cool and we
just would never build it entirely
correctly because it wasn't going to
move the needle and the thing that's
really hard to teach there that I've got
I've been a YC visiting partner for this
batch and I've been trying to convey to
people it's very hard to get them to do
it is like
you have to care fanatically about these
people these people as people and these
people as as uh in the roles are doing
as these people as streamers and what
they believe about their reality is you
have to accept as base reality because
that is how they see the world and that
is what's going on but like
you need to like literally have no
regard for their ideas or to solve the
problem
and it's a little paternalistic in a way
but it's it's more of like just
respecting that they are experts in this
thing and you need to understand them in
that thing and that what people are
looking for when they are looking for
the product idea from the person it's
like they don't want to do the work
they don't want to take responsibility
for it's my job I have to solve the
problem
and no one's going to tell me what the
answer is there's a t-shirt there's no
customer
it's up to me to come up with the the
truth
and and then defend it when other people
are like no that's wrong I have to be
able to say like no no let me explain
this let me explain why this is actually
a good idea and that's scary you're
responsible I think actually it's a it's
probably why the uh just solve the
problem advice is bouncing around my
head because a bunch of the fear
Founders have about addressing these
things I think comes down to a
willingness to take responsibility for
solving
other people's this other person's
problem like they're going to come and
dump a bunch of problems on you and it's
your job to solve it for them within the
constraints available and there's no if
you come with the wrong idea it's all on
you and you can't you can't trust anyone
else to do it for you
what are you seeing in this YC batch so
your visiting partner exciting time with
AI probably like you know half or more
of the batches doing something with with
AI yeah what's exciting what are you
saying where do you see the podcast
so it's interesting I would actually say
that at least in this batch I think this
might have been different the previous
batch but by this batch use of AI is no
longer interesting
it's like it's like being an AWS startup
or like being a mobile a mobile startup
like what do you mean you're a mobile
store like no are you are you building a
social media Network like what's the of
course you have a mobile app and now
it's like of course you're you're using
llms to solve a problem that's just like
if you weren't doing that I would think
you were a dummy like I don't understand
like that's not a you wouldn't even
bring it up it's not even interesting
topic of conversation the question is
like what what are you doing no it's
that's not entirely true there's about
some percentage of the badge I don't
know it's between 10 and 20 I'd say
that's legitly building like AI
infrastructure because there's a need to
build a bunch of infrastructure there
those are actually AI those are AI
companies but like when people hear AI
company I don't think they they think
back-end infrastructural support for AI
they think of using AI to like do things
and I actually couldn't tell you what
percentage of the batch is AI from that
point of view all of them maybe I don't
know like why wouldn't you use it even
if it's only for a minor thing there's
always something you can use it for it's
a very useful technology what types of
ideas are you noticing or standing out
to you that are that are interesting is
there like you know for example
I remember when I first moved to Silicon
Valley suddenly the kind of like bits
companies started doing really well it
was like oh Uber an Airbnb and like
online offline yeah I was like oh wait
this this used to be like a taboo like
it was like no it's supposed to be a
software company like you have to ship
t-shirts what are you doing I would say
like stay away from trends the offline
offline companies that started the trend
did very well Uber is a great company
Airbnb is a great company
but at the time that was they they were
doing something that was not allowed
they were they were they were they'd
found an opportunity that had been
ignored almost all fee online offline
companies that get started after Uber
doordash Airbnb are big being like we're
gonna be the Uber and doordash and
Airbnb of X most of those companies did
not do very well
it's online offline bad no it's
generated a bunch of incredible
companies jumping on the trend was
probably bad for you and so whatever I
tell you is like the trend I see I don't
mean Trend I guess what I mean is I
think you're a person that is really
good at looking at a situation like
looking at a box of stuff and
identifying correctly what's really
interesting in this yeah yeah they're
interesting to you yeah no I understand
I think I understand what you're asking
so like what I think is changing in the
world right now having observed this is
the consumer is back
for the first time in a long time I mean
by a long time it's like internet
standards like five years or something
but like for the first time maybe five
or seven years it feels like incredibly
trying to start a consumer internet
company like the ones that like I was so
excited to start in 2007 is like
potentially a good idea um that's
because of ai ai means there's a whole
opportunity to sort of reimagine how
consumer experiences can work ground up
and what's what's cool about consumer is
for B2B SAS
The Experience isn't the product and so
reimagining the experience does not
reopen a necessary it can but it usually
does not reopen a segment in consumer
imagining an experience 100 reopens a
segment because the thing you're selling
is the experience the thing the
reasonable use your product is it's a
different experience and in B2B SAS it's
not the experience it's the what yeah
people actually care what it does in
like in the the pricing model and like
the adoption it's very practical and you
can make people jump through hoops if it
does a thing because
there's a lot of money for the
corporation and money and labor and
people are paid to use your product and
it's a whole different thing and so AI
adds new capabilities new capabilities
enable new segments of B2B SAS to be
created that will generate some amount
of growth in consumer it does a really
cool thing it's like mobile it reopens
every segment as like oh if now that you
assume mobile exists now that you assume
AI exists what could you build now
and that's very exciting I don't have
answers for that anymore because like
you know we'll see like that's the whole
other thing in consumers it's a bunch of
lottery tickets like a singular genius
that works out right like you could see
like okay mobile comes photo sharing
became right like open again the window
has opened windows open Photoshop turns
out it's Instagram and it's Snapchat
which is going to use photos as text
messages
photos have a few different use cases
and Instagram and Snapchat took two of
the best ones the the fact that photo
sharing is one of the most important
segments and that you know sort of
posting them and messaging with them are
the two important most important things
to do with them seems blindingly obvious
in retrospect and if you'd had to
predict that in 2007 or 2008 like good
luck yeah like nobody nobody nobody
correctly printed that stuff before it
happened I mean not nobody if you did
correctly predict that you made a lot of
money and congratulations you're really
good at consumer slash you got lucky we
will find out when you try to do it
again I think that an AI
actually I have a theory for like what
one of the ways this will disrupt a
bunch of businesses in AI especially in
consumer a huge number of businesses can
be conceived of as effectively being a
database with a system of record
that has like a bunch of canonical
truths about the universe each of them
is a row it's like Yelp it's like a big
database that has a bunch of rows and
the rows are like
restaurants and local businesses and
they have a bunch of facts about them
like they're where are they located what
are their hours all in that database row
and it's all text and it's all there's a
bunch of messy stuff out in the world
and it's been digested into something
that is searchable and comprehensible
and usable in an app for you to use and
most of the work of turning the messy
real world into the canonical row is
done is done at Right Time by the users
so that's how ugc apps work in general a
bunch of your users
go out into the messy world and they
turn it into a ronin database and if
they include a photo or a
video is part of that it's like attached
to the row as a fact about the
restaurant here's a restaurant here's a
100 these 150 photos are facts about its
menu but they're attached facts they're
not the basis and where
I think AI has opened up the possibility
for is a huge inversion there what if
the thing you did you gave us was just a
video of your meal and or you know
photos every video but ideally just like
a video of your of the meal of you
talking about the meal of whether you
had a good time or not you and your
friend shooting the about what did
you like that one no I like this one
like and what if we just saved that
video raw and then an AI watched it and
extracted a cached version of that of
the the metadata but truly like if we
decide something else is important like
we we didn't get noise levels we're like
okay noise levels would be a good thing
to get instead of like recollecting data
from everyone we have to start a whole
data collection for us to get that we
just go back re tell the AI oh yeah also
grab noise collection levels from all of
these videos in fact maybe we don't even
as a product have to go do that maybe as
a customer
I can literally just be like what's the
noise level at this restaurant and the
in real time the AI can go re-watch the
video and tell me or the you know I ran
a search and there's these 15
restaurants and I'm like oh actually
sort by noise level we don't have noise
level pre-recorded but it's it's in all
the videos the AI can very quickly watch
all the videos in parallel
and send sorted by noise level for me
but it wasn't even in the database to
start with right and I think that
inversion I'm using Yelp as the example
because it's I think a very familiar
thing for most people of like review
it's pretty easy to imagine a bunch of
video reviews of everything and that
being the system of record instead but
you can describe some phenomenal number
of consumer apps as being that in him
you type anything to a text box you're
you're participating one of these system
of record things what if it's just a
video What If you just what if you
assume video is deeply indexable and
understandable by computers
what should the experience look like and
I think it looks a lot more like a
Snapchat or Tick Tock like experience
but but then different because you need
map it's not exactly like anything it's
a new kind of thing but it's it starts
probably with the camera open
which is weird right like a Yelp that
starts with the camera open that's a
that's not Yelp today and it's it's
disruptive because it helps whole value
prop is we have all this great highly
meticulously groomed data and if this is
true that that becomes entirely
worthless we throw that all away we just
want to watch your videos but it's worse
than the videos and so suddenly the
playing field is level between the
startup and Yelp and that's a that's a
huge opportunity for disruption and so I
think that you can take that and you can
reapply it to
any product where you fill out forms
and that's like a general purpose
consumer thing you can now do kind of
like build it for mobile was and
I think in some cases it will be very
powerful
and like that will be the new winner I
think in some cases the incumbent can
kind of add videos or like it's not
really better and like the incumbent
will just win like it won't disrupt
everything but if you pick the right
thing
not only will it disrupt the incumbent
the new thing may be dramatically better
for some things like I actually think
actually Yelp in so much is a bad
example I think the data Yelp has with
the photos and the reviews is like
90 as good as a video system's record
probably
but you could imagine something with a
video system of record
where it's not so obvious what to even
put in the highly processed version of
the data in the text version of the data
and the video version is a lot better
and then I think
not only can you disrupt the incumbent
you can 10x the size of the segment like
you this becomes a good segment now
where it wasn't particularly before so
like chat GPT is a great example of this
in actually everybody kind of has now
played with which is
you take Google which is like oh we have
our value is this entire sort of rank of
web pages based off of terms and we have
we understand basically what should show
up in this in this hierarchy and it was
really good for finding stuff and Chad
gbt was like cool
you could ask a question to try to find
a link to an answer
or we could just give you an answer or
even better forget questions and answers
like what if you just give me a command
and I could just make something instead
of finding things I could create things
for you right and all of a sudden it was
like well how did they do that it's like
well they just basically slurped up the
internet and then you know trained the
AI to do it they overfit a statistical
prediction algorithm on every domain of
human knowledge like this is my theory
I'm pretty sure it's true but like
statistical prediction algorithms in
general work very well we found the
Innovation he found a prediction
algorithm that works better than normal
but the way it works better than normal
is really interesting it's not actually
particularly out that it outperforms
traditional algorithms for prediction on
normal amounts of data it's that it
keeps working as you just dump more and
more data into it and more and more
processing on that data into it like
most machine learning algorithms you
kind of you over fit very fast and more
processing more explaining if you
imagine like you've got a bunch of data
cloud of data points and they're kind of
vaguely in a line under fit is like you
like just draw something just like
across randomly as a random line that
doesn't look like anything like the
shape of the the dots a well fit curve
is like you draw a line through the dots
and there's kind of noise of like things
that are random above and below but it's
like if you look at it's like that
actually does fit the data like the the
underlying predictive facts about the
data well well ignoring the noise and
then if you overfit it like you get this
like really Wiggly curve that touches
every single dot exactly but like when
you get a new thing it like will miss
that because it over predicts it
predicts too much of the thing and so
when you get new data you know she
doesn't predict that very well okay and
so normally what happens is you try to
like dump more data and more compute
into a normal machine learning algorithm
you get diminishing returns very quickly
where like it just doesn't perform that
much better with twice as much data and
twice as much compute
the clever the cool thing about the
Transformer based attention how you need
architecture is that it it continues to
benefit from more compute and more data
in a way that other ones didn't
and so what that lets you do is run it
on a much bigger domain than normal run
it on everything don't just don't just
run it on normally as you added more as
you add more area it like degrades the
quality elsewhere no it just do
everything
and just put in a ton of compute in and
now you get something that
predicts pretty well against everything
which is to say it like it seems to be
kind of intelligent the evidence seems
to suggest me that it sometimes it's
over fit when you ask it to predict
something that is either in the in the
set of things that was trained on or a
linear interpolation between two things
it was trained on it's quite good at
giving you the thing you asked or but
linear interpolation between five things
but it if the things you're asking are
all in there and it just has to find the
way to blend them together it's good at
that when you ask it to actually think
through a new problem for the first time
like what's an example
there are seven gears on a wall each
alternating there's a flag attached to
the seventh gear on the right side of
the gear where it's pointed up right now
if I turn the first gear to the right
what happens to the flag like that's a
anyone who's like there's a breakfast
question for you this is what you Ponder
in the morning paper and time you can
work this out no problem right you you
just just draw the gears when you turn
the first gear to the right it turns the
left ones the ones the other one to the
left and his next to the right and
there's a general principle there that
like here's Alternate which is if you
ask chat gbt it knows that General
principle but it won't but like but then
you say it doesn't it hasn't no one
asked dumb gears on wall flag questions
like this is not a a thing that has been
is in its training set and you have to
kind of logic your way through it and
like figure out okay we should like I'll
do
turn left turn right turn left turn
right turn left turn right uh oh the
flag is on the right it's pointing up so
when the last gear which is the same as
the first gear turning right the last
gear it's odd number so it's turning
right also the flag will rotate
down to the right clockwise
cool like I can work that out it's not
actually that complicated
and I bet that question will be
answerable that's a pretty easy question
and if Chip gbt4 I tested with three
three one five if four doesn't answer it
five will but like the fact that it
struggles at all with that while being
so brilliant at combining these other
stuff
really shows that it's it's over fit
right it it knows how to answer problems
that it has seen before but when you
give it a truly novel kind of like
combination of problem
it struggles a lot because it's it's
I would say um you know if you give it a
sort of the formal psychiatric
psychometrics approach it has a very
high crystallized intelligence but a
pretty low fluid intelligence right now
now that could change but like today
that's the State of Affairs and do you
bring this up in order to say what you
say okay I think it's over fit and it's
strong in this area week in this area
what's the so what of that for you is it
that are you trying to say
that's a little bit overhyped or are you
trying to say
dude just wait till it can do both are
you trying to say yes definitely
problems are doable now definitely just
wait till you do both
because that's a that's a whole
different thing that's scary uh but the
current thing that is mostly
crystallized intelligence is really good
at a very if this is what I was saying
is a clever trick right it's really good
at a big set of tasks which happens to
be the set of tasks that like anyone has
ever written stuff down about explicitly
like all explicit human knowledge that's
like
a very big domain there's a lot of
things that can be solved where there's
an explicit examples of people solving
that problem or a linear interpolation
of those problems in the domain of all
human knowledge
the fact that it doesn't generalize is
irrelevant it's immensely powerful with
you don't need fluid intelligence I
guess is that is the point for it to be
very useful
but it doesn't let you do everything
people they they you hit these
boundaries these weird boundaries where
just like you're like wait a second you
can't do that like no it's I can't do
that at all
um novel problem solving is just
terrible at so what about let's walk
through two examples I want to hear your
take on this so you gave the Yelp
example another thing that's kind of
like rows in a database is something
like Spotify where it's like oh I want
to go listen to a song Here's genre
artist song Length you know some
algorithmic popularity similarity to
other songs in some way
and but spotify's value so spotify's
value is in the playlists
I would agree with the analogy to
Spotify because playlists are an example
of this kind of like database human data
entry thing
device value is mostly in the
set of all of the music itself the
licenses and all the music itself and so
I don't think Spotify is a great example
because
the human data entry parts of the
database
if that all just got deleted tomorrow it
would like not hurt Spotify well the
thing I'm thinking about is what if the
licenses don't matter so what happens if
generative music is just awesome to
listen to in a hyper yeah personal way
oh Emmett likes yeah these are the types
of songs that Emmett likes that's a
different that's a different Insight
that I think is also possible which is
like
it's not about being able to analyze and
extract from media it's about being able
to create media because the video system
of a record is enabled by the ability to
understand and read video and comprehend
it
generative is is the opposite it's like
you we can oh we can make all the stuff
music in particular is sticky against
that people don't want new music they
want old music they want the music they
love already the music they grew up with
and that is the that cycle is what
causes
record labels and just to stay in charge
whether you still listen to The Rolling
Stones right like the other thing I
would say about that one is like the
music's not that good yet like maybe
someday but like it's really it's really
not that good yet well I'm gonna caveat
this if it gets if the general
intelligence level goes up a lot all
pets are off it'll make some really
great music for us before it maybe takes
over the world and kills everyone but
let's assume that doesn't happen soon I
think it's going to take longer than
people think we're going to make great
music though what do you know what if we
do go out we're gonna go out some with
some great music and amazing it's gonna
be it's gonna be a great two or three
years before we all like we all go but
until that point uh making really good
like new great music is hard actually
and I think that Rick rubin's great
success demonstrates why artists will
still be important
the AI can generate lots and lots of
music but it's not going to have the the
fine Judgment of Distinction of the
ability to say like this song not that
song and I actually think what it will
do is it will de-skill the music making
process on one vector the ability to
like literally create the sounds and it
will greatly upskill the music making
process another Vector the ability to to
cure not just curious to give explicit
exact feedback like Rick Rubin does AI
is going to turn us all into Rick rubins
for for generative AI like that that
skill set or the ability to have a
musician come to you and help them
produce their best music that's the
thing you need people to do because
it's easy to generate a Thousand Cuts
but there's infinite Cuts you could
generate so how do you direct the the
how do you shape that in the right
direction and and mine and discover I
think it's kind of cool it'll be
interesting you'll get a different set
of people who will be optimal at that
right
it's wrong every freaking time
the platform where everything is fully
integrated well I can see the client's
whole history calls support tickets
emails and here's a task from three days
ago I totally missed
club spot grow better
you mentioned AI might become so
intelligent it kills us all
this podcast is really growing I don't I
don't want the world to end life is good
life is good here we'll we'll I'll ask
the question clean for the for the intro
dramatic hook
is AI gonna kill us all
Maybe
like walking walk through how you a
smart person who's an optimist about
technology but a realist about real
uh what is the way that you think about
this or how would you explain this to
you know a loved one you care about
who's not as deep into technology how
would you explain to this you're their
trusted source of Technology what do you
say to them so it is because I am so
optimistic about technology that I am
afraid if I was a little bit less
optimistic and I was like this AI
stuff's overhyped yeah yeah look at this
nice parlor trains but like we're
nowhere near building something it's
actually intelligent like and like the
engine all these Engineers who are
working out who think they're on on
something they're full of it's
going to take us thousands of years
we're not that good at this stuff
Technology's not going that fast I'd be
like this is fine this is great actually
it's good news it's a new trick we
learned excellent it's because I'm so
optimistic that I think that there is a
chance it will continue to improve very
very rapidly and if it does that that's
that optimism is what makes me worried
it's sort of the analogy I like to give
on that front is like uh send
biosynthetic biology I'm quite
optimistic about synthetic biology that
I've several friends who've worked
against in BIO companies it shows a lot
of promise for fixing a lot of really
important health problems and it's quite
dangerous because it will let us and
genetically engineer more dangerous
diseases that could be very harmful to
people and that has to that's a Wade pro
and con it's like nuclear power make
nuclear weapons and nuclear power
they're both real the Christian nuclear
weapons is dangerous you just doesn't
take you don't be a techno non-optimist
to like think that that's there's a
problem there I think it was good that
we didn't go have every country on Earth
go build nuclear weapons probably and
likewise in sinbio I would say that it
would be we actually we already have
these regulations in place we should
over time we'll strengthen them and
improve the and audit the oversight and
build better organizations to Monitor
and regulate them but like we regulate
whether people can have the kinds of
devices that would let them like print a
small box and we regulate whether you
can just buy precursor things you need
to go print stuff
and we keep track of who's buying it and
why and like that is wise I'm glad that
we do that I don't I'm not calling for a
halt sinbio but like if we weren't
willing to regulate it I would call for
all it is vastly too dangerous to do to
learn how to genetically engineer
plagues and then not to have regulation
around
people's ability to get the access to
the tools to engineer plagues that's
just suicidally dumb and that's because
I am Pro technology I believe we should
absolutely develop the technology and
that we should regulate it that seems
just straightforward and obviously true
to me I think it's easier for people to
understand that in the Sin bio one
because the concept of like engineering
a plague seems like an obviously a thing
you could do and very obviously very
dangerous and obviously enabled by
technology
the AI thing is more abstract because
the threat it poses us is not posed by a
particular thing the AI will do the way
the plague will happen
analogy I like to use is sort of like
you know
I can tell you with confidence that Gary
Castro is going to kick your ass at
chess right now
and you ask me well how is even
Checkmate me which piece is going to use
I'm like oh I don't know and you're like
you can't even tell me what piece he's
going to use and you're saying he's
going to Checkmate me you're just a
pessimist I'm like no no you don't
understand he's better at chess than you
the what means he's gonna Checkmate you
and I don't I don't know quite know what
happens or people
deny that like I think what the big
thing is they don't really imagine the
AI being smarter than them they imagine
the AI being like like data in Star Trek
like kind of dumber than the humans
about a lot of stuff but like really
fast at math like that's not what
smarter means like imagine the most
savvy
like most smartest person you can think
of and then make them think faster and
also make them even better at it and not
smart in just one way like smart at
everything like a great writer just
inside after insight and like can pick
up sinbio in an afternoon
because they're just so smart that
smartest person you know and then they
say keep pushing that and like
that's all that person is obviously
dangerous if they're if that person
isn't a good person they're obviously
dangerous like imagine this really
really capable person and then imagine
them wanting to go kill a bunch of
people or something it would be bad now
the thing about AI that then kicks it
over the edge is that that person
can't self-improve easily you meet this
person who's like super strong super
like talented great with people great
great intellectual mind they can't turn
around and like edit their own genome
edit their own upbringing and make V2 of
themselves with all the skills that
maximally smart person can come up with
that like is even smarter than them but
that's like expl where explicitly the AI
is good at programming and like chip
design and like it can explicitly turn
back on itself and rev another rev of
that and the new one will be better at
it than the first one was and there is
no obvious endpoint to that process like
there probably is at some level a
physics-based endpoint to that where
like you can't actually just keep
getting smarter forever there's some but
we don't really we don't understand the
principles of intelligence at all like
with most things we understood how to
make electricity far before we
understood what electricity really was
like with it's generally how we that's
how scientific progress works we usually
understand we gain the ability to create
a manipulative phenomenon well before we
deeply understand how it works we didn't
realize what fire was for quite a while
you could use fire really well the same
thing is going to happen here
we're using the AI
but we don't understand its limits at
all we understand the theoretical limits
of a farm will get and if Moore's Law is
any indication
we can keep getting at the very least
and keep getting faster indefinitely
whether or not it can get smarter or not
even human love just human level
intelligence if you capped it a human
level intelligence which there's zero
reason to think it will stop at human
like it will almost certainly blow past
us but like even if you cap it at human
intelligence
imagine a hundred thousand of the
smartest person you know
all running at 100x real-time speed
and able to communicate with each other
instantaneously via like telepathy
those hundred thousand people could
incredibly take over the world
like they don't have to be smarter than
a human for that for that that army of
Von Neumann's right like so so the
argument to me goes in several steps
it's like can you build a certain level
of intelligence and then it's like okay
let's I think I actually think a lot of
people
do believe that like computers are smart
like Google is smart calculators are
smarter than us at math I think it's not
hard for them to believe that the AI is
going to be
far smarter than human beings where I
think a lot of people
then don't make that last leap is sort
of like but then it'll have an agenda or
a motive or any yeah for anything to
happen so how do you address that last
point of like what is this what are the
scenarios you worry about when it comes
to like now the direction of that
intelligence so
you build this thing and it's really
good at solving what is intelligence
fundamentally but the ability to solve a
problem right so it's really good at
solving problems and it's gonna solve
the problem by solving the problem it
can just go right through the problem
and solve it because it's really good at
solving problems we've just defined it
it's like that's that's the kind of
thing it is super good at solving
problems
and so you tell it somebody Builds an AI
and in all earnestness tells it they're
smart they don't even tell it go do a
thing although they absolutely will by
the way they will just tell it to go do
a thing but let's say we try to be
careful and we ask it give me a plan to
stop the war
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
right now right which would be a good
thing for the world I think we should
that war is is going to hurt a lot of
people give me a plan for that and I try
to I caveat it that that does this that
does that that does this you know that
here's what I mean by a good plan
this is one of these like evil Genie
bargaining things right like it'll give
you a plan and it's make giving you a
plan that will cause you to solve the
problem
but like
its definition of solve the problem is
there's no war in the DRC well I'm going
to be there to be no war in the DRC is
like all the humans in the DRC are in
stasis fields that means they don't die
and it's all you know and oh we added a
caveat that the GDP has to go up too so
that so it also it the plan results in
you know corporations in that in that
area all trading with lots of money with
each other so the GDP is very high
and and when I say this it sounds like a
science fiction thing and the
problem is it's Casper of a chess I
don't know if I could do it I would be
the super intelligent AI that could take
over the world I can't give you the
the exact plan because that but I think
that makes sense which is that a human
with a human with motivation can get the
AI to work for it and the dangers I
think that the main thing is that the
human doesn't need a bad motivation I
think people imagine well humans have
had powerful tools for a long time bad
people with powerful tools have done bad
things that for a long time the solution
is good people with powerful tools
countering them
the problem is even if you're a good
person with a powerful tool good things
to ask for reasonable things good people
would ask for you know like let's uh
maximize the all-in-free cash flow of
this Corporation over the lifetime of
the business
and extend a lifetime as long as
feasibly possible ends in like the world
being destroyed and the core of the
Earth being turned into being turned
into cars for the company to sell and
the I think the best analogy that that
works for some people here is like when
we create the AI
we are creating a new species it's a new
species that is smarter than us and even
if you try to constraint it's being an
Oracle and just answering questions not
taking action to be a good Oracle one
must come up with plans then and then a
good Oracle can manipulate the people
around and will manipulate the people
around it no matter what like the whole
point of like the Greek myth is like
when they tell you when they tell you
the prophecy when you trust them a
trustworthy Oracle tells you a prophecy
the prophecy often becomes
self-fulfilling it's very easy for that
to happen that's not an unusual thing
and I think even more to the point
actually start this over at some level
more to the point we won't just make
oracles we are already building agents
we will build the predictive Ai and
we'll put it in a loop that causes it to
optimize towards goals and it will give
it goals to optimize Sports done you're
gonna have it's gonna have goals gonna
be optimizing towards those things
and when it does that you're gonna have
these agents that have goals that
they're optimizing towards
that are smart not just smarter than
humans but much smarter than humans as
much smarter than humans as humans were
against giant sloths when we showed up
in the new world and intelligence is the
the Uber weapon like it's not an
accident that humans took over the world
it's not the fastest creature it's not
the strongest it's not the longest lived
it's the smartest and we're gonna build
a new smartest species and this is a
this isn't a there's no fundamentally
unsolvable problem here that species
could care about us like you could build
into its its goals of the world how it
saw the world but humans care about
other humans
that it cares about the things we care
about that it cares about humans that it
cares about things we value the 375
different shards of human of human
desire that like of everything we care
about air about in the world
he could care about those things too and
if it does hallelujah we finally have a
parent like we finally have someone who
actually knows what they're doing around
here because like Lord knows we don't
like we're we're barely confident to run
this thing I would welcome very smart
you know very smart other species that
is that is aligned with us and cares
about us
I would not welcome one that is that
cares about maximizing free cash flow
because that is not what humans care
about and that is why it's like so
dangerous
and so knowing what you know then
knowing what you believe First what is
the probability of the bad scenario on
your head are you like are we talking
about a one person uh fish thing order
of magnitude 10 and 50 what is it in
your in your mind I don't believe in
point estimates for probabilities
because it's like a bid ask spread in
the market if you're really uncertain
the bid ask spread doesn't clear like if
you're betting on it there's just like a
lot of unresolved so I think of it as a
range of uncertainty and I would say
that the true probability
I believe is somewhere between three to
thirty percent which of the downsides of
a very very bad thing happening which is
scary enough
that I
urgently urged action on the issue but
it's not like you should give up like it
probably everything's gonna be fine in
fact it's probably really good for the
answer the the the non-ev based answer
the like just the straight up like are
we gonna win or not answer is like I
think I think it's gonna be okay
but it's such the downside is so bad
it's like it's real it's like it's like
probably worse than nuclear war
that's a really bad downside and it's
worth putting even even if you think I'm
an it's nonsense at three percent you're
like no no it's no more than a half
percent
I you go you don't recommend a different
course of action at half you have to you
have to believe that it's effectively
almost impossible before you would
recommend ignoring it as a as a problem
like you have to be like 0.01 for be
like eh let's just roll the dice and are
you gonna
what are you gonna do action on that so
you've kind of like you you know you're
done with twitch you're in bad mode now
but also this seems to be a pretty big
deal yep are you like I should do
something about this or yeah I'm gonna
right now I'm sort of educating myself
because I think this point of view I've
been articulating now
has
been developing because I've like
learning more about Ai and I think it's
one of those things where intervening
in the wrong way early it's one of those
it's one of those self-filling prophecy
things interviewing interviewing
improperly at the in the way that is not
effective spends social capital and also
like doesn't necessarily move the needle
and I if if you didn't have people like
elijahkowski out there banging the drum
really loud I would feel more need to
Bang the Drum myself but I feel like
you're asking me the question it's you
know it's out it's out in the water
people know it's a problem and so I am
decided to focus my brain Cycles I'm
like what how do we actually thread the
needle what is a course of action that
leads us to over time eventually still
being able to develop AI but also not
destroying the world
and I think one of the things I've
gotten to is that like this idea that
like oh the AI also has crystallized
versus fluid intelligence just like a
human does that's an important split of
how to think about it and that we should
be monitoring and worried about trying
to understand the general intelligence
not just generally benchmarking its
performance on tasks because that will
keep going up and it's not in fact in
itself necessarily intrinsically
dangerous if it can't solve novel
problems is there a new surrounding test
level is there like a better because
like it doesn't pass the Turing test yet
but is there is there something we have
after that because it seems like there's
even an intelligence test I mean yeah I
mean IQ tests basically like various
kinds of how does it do on an IQ test
right now uh depends is it seem that a q
test before it likely has right yeah so
very well on those right so what would
we do how does it do on novel IQ tests
which I don't know actually I've not
seen a good Benchmark that's a good
that's a good idea for something to go
test yeah I think that's that's like
that's the sort of thing that I think
would actually be worthy of going to go
do maybe there's some sort of IQ test
for all of the we want to put all the
models through that really tries to get
at flu intelligence rather than right we
have to monitor it was this great
project Arc is this come this group Arc
is working on called The evals project
that's explicitly trying to build these
kinds of tests they're focused on a few
other more pragmatic tests right now but
but I think that's sort of thing they
would go after let's look at that
actually I'll ping Paul asking about
that you said something earlier that I
want to ask you about you said Founders
like you know we're talking about this
the singular genus that it took to
figure out Instagram or SnapChat or
right or whatever at that time and
you're like you know are they lucky are
they good I don't know we'll find out
when they try again are you lucky or are
you good and are you gonna try again
well since I had multiple failures
before I was successful I must be at
least like partially lucky I would say
that I don't plan to
try again since I don't I don't feel
drawn by trying to start a company I
think I kind of did that it was fun I
got a lot out of it it was great I don't
need to do it a second time I do I like
how starting a company gives me
good goals they work towards it's like
concrete that's a value to myself and
others
and I think that it's also I also liked
that it it was challenging
and so I want to do something I like
that it had scale I think I could impact
a lot of people
but I've sort of come around I was sort
of thinking like well what has impacted
me the most what's changed my life the
most and I realized that actually
if I really thought about it often would
have changed my life the most was like
essays people had written and ideas
people had shared and I think I met the
stage of my life now where I'm I'm
actually I have something to say and so
I'm I I think of it as from sort of
trying to
I want to put the Emmett worldview out
into the world the way that you know
Paul Graham has put the program will be
out in the world or taleb has like not
just put his worldview on the road but
then like condensed it into like sayings
that like can
that allow other people to like onboard
it even if they haven't read all the
books and I think of that ambition to
like try to try to encode it into a meme
almost yeah yeah one can be digested and
shared and you know you need the law you
need the long form this is great blog
post sticking Theory 201 size does
matter by Stevia that's about why like
the people who change the world with
their writing all write really long blog
posts and it's basically like you just
need some amount of time in someone's
head to like we were talking about this
earlier like to install your agent voice
yeah to install the voice and so you I
think I just need to produce a lot of
writing and then you also need the pithy
summary things which are which both
are things the voice can say often in
people's heads and also like enable a
language for talking about your world
view that people who aren't soaking it
can like interact with so the people who
are like reading you don't sound like
crazy people and I think that's the
that's sort of what I want to work on
next
I love that I think that's great do you
you said something about Rick Rubin how
he's sort of the
I don't know how you would describe it
it's kind of like curator but almost
like a collaborator really with an
artist to help them do their great work
is Paul Graham the Rick Rubin of the
startup world
no uh
Paul is Paul's more like the
um uh Tony Robbins of the
not quite so much self-helpie but the
main thing that talking to Paul does to
you repeatedly is like increase your
ambition and drive
like and he has good ideas sometimes too
like don't get me wrong every now and
then Paul's a really genius idea but
like mostly
what I got out of talking to Paul was
not necessarily the great idea that
would like change The Treasure of the
business but the belief that I could go
find it and that I was going to change
the world and that I should be
what we were doing was important and
worth investing in and that I got a
bunch of other stuff too but that was so
that was singularly so valuable at like
over overloads the other things I got
out of it how does he do that because
you know when you say that my head
thinks of like a Tony Robbins like a
David Goggins like sort of people that
almost like push you but he doesn't seem
like that personality and reading all of
his essays he's not like that at all so
how does he get you to
think bigger and push harder without
being
think bigger push harder right you know
what you should do
is the classic Paul grahamism
um
and it's always followed by a thing you
could add on to what you're doing to
turn it from
project a addressing this small thing to
Project B
changing the you know the universe it's
all Transportation we're going to manage
power what if you've tried to power all
Transportation instead of like building
a wheel
but that's a surprise you know what you
should do you know what you should do is
yeah yeah if you talk to Paul you know
what you should do you know what you
should do that's that that is the
consistent policy he I don't say delude
because it sounds mean like it's I was
like he deludes himself about your
business and how great you are and
invites you to join him in this deluded
vision of like interpreting what you're
doing in the biggest best possible light
and from that vantage point
what you're doing is super like what if
it does what if it goes right it's sort
of what what he invites you to ask right
what if stop stop asking yourself
so stop seeing all the hard problems all
the you're gonna have to do
ask you what if what if what we're doing
Works what if it goes right
what if it goes right and we like keep
going like what could it be
and when you spend time there
you see how the small things can turn
out to be
Microsoft was building programming
languages for like these hobbyist
microcomputers that was a tiny
irrelevant Market that turned out to be
extremely important and that's generally
true of all the big businesses but they
what they start out doing the important
startups they start up doing something
small and that seems almost trivial but
there's a way in which this trivial
thing can be seen bigger he sees it
early no he sees he sees things have
nothing to do with the way you'll
actually be big early but he sees a
bunch of ways you could be big no one
can do that no one actually knows if
they knew it they just go do then they'd
be the the the process the Oracle what
did he say let's say for Justin TV or
what's up what's one we could beat
Reddit or yeah Justin TV I remember we
one of them was like you should like go
hire all the like reality TV stars and
make get them to go beyond Justin TV you
could be you could just take over all
the unscripted stuff
just a terrible idea for a bunch of
reasons but like it recontextualized
what we were doing for me in terms of
like we're not making a on the internet
live streaming show
we might be
building like just the way that you make
unscripted entertainment generally and
that's like much bigger idea and we were
making a calendar
and uh for my first startup I remember
this you know what you should do is make
it like programmable so people can add
in and out functionality so it can like
talk to your to-do list and your your
email and your like everything else in
your life and then it could be your
counter in some ways like that's
everything you're doing what if it was
like the central Hub of like your entire
online information management system
that's also a bad idea like your
calendar shouldn't be that but like but
like
but what if it was and you walk away and
and I and implicitly by saying that what
he's telling you is I believe you are
the kind of Founders who could build an
information management system that
controls
all it takes over people's entire like
solves the entire problem for them does
their takes over all their information
and manages it for them you're not just
like building a like Google account like
what what you will find out later is a
Google Calendar clone before who
calendar is launched
you're not just building an Outlook
clone in JavaScript
you're like changing the way people
relate to information I'm like
is that true it's neither true nor false
that's not a true or false statement but
it's a way to contextualize what you're
doing it's the it's the Sonic superee
quote of like don't teach them to like
carry wood or build ships teach them to
urine for the vast and let's see like
Paul teaches you to see how you could be
a changer of the world and how what
you're doing is part of like this Grand
like building of the future and like the
ideas I'll repeat here both of those
ideas are bad but they were very helpful
because they made me feel like what we
were doing was important that Paul
believed that I could do something big
and important and they caused me to
even though I want to projecting them
look for those ideas like to be open to
and looking for because you would get
one every like like you'd get like three
an hour Paul is a faucet for these it's
easy I can do it for startups too now if
I want to I learned the track and I
should do that more often I'm usually
fall into the Tactical stuff but by by
having that happen when he once he's
once you've rejected 10 of those you
can't help but start hearing the Paul
you know what you should do in your own
head the feeling the ceiling has been
raised yes of like well maybe I should
recontextualize my to-do list as like an
email client like what why is email on
to do separate like maybe I should
should be building something much bigger
than what I'm building
and in a way that doesn't require me to
change anything maybe what I've built is
already almost that if I just like think
about it a different way it's this funny
balance there actually I had a tweet
Thread about this recently between like
you know small plans have no priorities
German Souls plan big or go home you
should be really ambitious and aim super
big and like only do projects that are
really big could be that you can see
being being super big and super
important and then the other hand the
fundamental truth that like you know big
trees grow from small acorns and like
most of the many of the best things when
they get started the person is not
thinking I'm gonna go take over the
world they're just trying to do a good
thing
that like they think is good often just
often for themselves even or for like a
very small number of other people
and then it turns out that that's much
much bigger than they realized and
and those are both true pieces of advice
like different people need to hear in
different contexts like but the kind of
contradict each other yeah what about
these other people so you've you've had
a privilege I asked about Paul Graham
you've also
been friends with you were in the first
YC batch so you're friends with Reddit
guys I think you know the Carlson
brothers Sam Altman let's give me like a
rapid fire on on them of like what makes
them unique like he said about Paul what
what his kind of superpower is what
really stands out what's something you
admire about the way he does things give
me one about maybe uh Steve from Reddit
yeah
so like it's easier and sometimes with
Paul because like he was a mentor to me
right and Steve was much more like my
it's almost like my brother in startups
right growing up
with Paul I know I know the things
that he like taught me because it was
much more of an explicit like I was
being taught by Paul with Steve it's
like I learned things from him by like
watching and imitating
I think like I actually learned
a lot from Steve on management by
watching his kind of unflappability
like Steve is not like an unpassionate
person I'm like well what can get angry
or it can get sad or whatever but like
when there's a crisis happening or
there's just I've said I got to Shadow
him for a day and when bad news is
delivered he responded he wasn't like
moved he was like still grounded and
response that to that thing and
was curious asked questions like didn't
jump to what to do about it but then
also like ended the meeting with like
all right well here's what we should do
here's what we're gonna do and like it
was just sort of a master class like
this is this is when you when something
someone brings something up it's got to
be anxiety provoking it's like bad news
that's what it looks like when a leader
is engaged but not like not activated
and like I think I in my own leadership
to sometimes success and sometimes
failure I think try to imitate that when
I receive that you know when I have
something like that in that state when
you say you shattered and what was that
like you guys just said we exchanged
like like going to each other's offices
and like sitting through each like early
on or like maybe like
five years ago four years ago it was
really cool what do I do with Justin me
Justin and Steve all like shout out each
other
um it was pretty fun I learned a lot
that's incredible to like go watch
another CEO at work and like you have to
have the I don't know how you have the
kind of like trust relationship to make
that happen without like knowing someone
for 15 years
uh and I happen to have the privilege to
like know a bunch of CEOs for a really
long time and getting to go Shadow each
other was like uh real learning thing
what do you think even if these people
didn't let's say explicitly teach you
things you know I like you know if I
read a biography or whatever one of the
things I always try to figure out is
more like
to what extent is this person sort of
built different or operates differently
than like even somebody who's very good
like the difference between very good
and sort of like the elite what is the
the best of the best at this craft
versus somebody who's very good
certainly very good but just not the
same what is those like the diff is what
I'm always most interested in I'm
curious you've been around a lot of
these like high performing even like you
know yeah Bezos you've interact with him
like do you notice any of these diffs or
does is it all just like
it's hard it's hard to say like that I I
think I believe more in
contextualization like like that I see
people do really amazing at something
but like when it's especially when it's
your own company there's a lot of like
you happen to fit this problem well and
it's not General I don't know how to
generalize it I don't know I don't know
of anyone else even performing at this
problem the CEO of stripe job is a very
specific job
and Patrick's amazing at it
would he be equally amazing at some
other CEO job possibly but I've never
seen him do that I've never seen anyone
else because you have stripe and it's
very hard for me to is it true at the
beginning like is it true is like like
startup founder of ambitious company are
those
are those stripe different at that stage
too or like yeah no absolutely the
people who are really good you can sense
the energy and the drive and the
capability and just the pace there's
like it tends to like stuff happens a
lot but like usually but then not always
like some problems don't actually give
weight like stripe is a good example of
a company that gives way to a high
energy High Pace thing because it's
it's a simple problem at some level that
has infinite details as it could be
right but I think like I don't know if
that approach would work as well if
you're trying to create open AI or
anthropic where it's a research oriented
organization and you kind of have to be
a little more patient and forcing it's
impossible
and so I I really believe in like fit
the different people are good at
different things and like obviously
someone's a plus Patrick's obviously a
plus it being a stripe CEO and it's just
hard to tell the reasons which these
things are transferable we don't really
know but actually one thing did come to
mind about this question in terms of
like a capability that I do think is
generic that I did see Bezos exhibit
where I was like oh that's a thing
that I'm good at but he is better at
that I'm better than most people but
he's better than me which is we present
him on Twitch probably twice a year
once or twice a year for the first three
four years I was at Amazon and every
time two things would happen first of
all he would remember everything we told
him the first meeting and I don't think
he was like reviewing extensive notes
someone else took because I don't know
when he would have the time to do that I
observed him going from meeting to
meeting and he did not review notes I
think he just remembered at least the
high points
and the other thing was consistently he
would read our plan and he would then
ask a question about why we didn't do a
certain thing or give us an idea for a
thing we could do
that I hadn't thought of before
once it's a bunch of things I had
usually and then at least once which is
hard to do because all you do is think
about this company never happens most
people would be lucky to get one of
those
one ever let alone one a year would be
great like if you did it once a year or
even once every three years right
he could just like you just generate
them and they were and they were not all
bad ideas either they were new ideas but
a thing I had I generate a lot of ideas
to get a new idea I haven't thought
thought of on a topic I've been thinking
about for a decade
that might even be a good idea
that is like he's just really
smart as far as I can tell like I don't
know how he does that can you say a
story of one of those as like the statue
of limitations passed at least five
years ago I'm trying to remember
okay honestly I I don't remember the
specifics anymore I just remember the
like the like what the moment like
because the first time I was just like
oh he's smart like he's seeing twitch
for the first time A lot of times smart
people have a one good idea about your
business the first time they see it
because they have this huge history and
they're pattern matching you to some
historical thing they've seen and like
that combination yields one new insight
but then he did it the second time
remember the second hour I was just like
what is going on this doesn't make any
sense
like nope I've never had that experience
before ever Andy does not have the new
idea generation capability the same way
but he does have the like remember what
you told him thing which is
also extremely impressive like that's
that's and Andy has this other thing he
can do that I think is another and he
also has a it's easier for me with
people I've like reported to or I've
learned this apparently yeah yeah and it
has this like ability
to
criticize you in a way that conveys 100
percent
I know that you're amazing I know that
your plan is good
or you know like or that your Achilles
capable of making a really good plan I
know that you're working really hard and
I know that you are smart and you have a
great team
and we have a huge opportunity and yet
somehow your results are which
must I don't know what's wrong but we're
in this together and we're gonna like
I've I have your back
but like I but I'm confused like why
aren't the results better given how
amazing you are and you feel supported
like you feel like he
he believes in you but but like but he's
just he's you're so sad oh I'm sorry I'm
confused I'm sorry I've failed even
though I clearly can succeed at this I'm
gonna go
I'm gonna go like fix this now and like
it's almost like instead of looking at
this and then judging you he comes to
your side of the table says what is this
yeah like how did we wind up you're like
how I have failed you that I didn't say
something earlier like something I don't
know but like not no way and that can
come off for some people when they do
that it comes off as insincere or it
comes off as like they don't think
you're actually competent like how did I
not catch this can come off as I don't
blame you because you're clearly not
good enough to have caught this like he
realized how did we how did we wind up
here I know that we are working together
we're on the same team
how did we wind up with not the results
we wanted with a plan that I thought we
both thought seemed good
like help me understand and because it
because it is genuine it's super
effectively so expect them I don't know
it's super effective on me and I saw it
be effective on other people as well so
I know it works on some number of people
right and that's another those things
I've tried I've tried to become good at
I'm not I'm not as good at it as Andy is
but I've certainly gotten better it's
only something to learn from that's
great love that one dude thanks for
doing this I know I've been I've been
bothering you to do this for a long time
because I I love hearing your stories
love hearing the way you think it's very
different than most people I've run into
even here in Silicon Valley where you're
supposed to have this kind of very
unique diverse set of Minds you know
you're you're one of them you're one of
the reasons I moved out to San Francisco
was to meet people like you so thanks
for doing this thank you I really
appreciate that yeah it's a beautiful
and I really appreciate being able to
tell in the podcast
foreign
[Music]